on this friday night
canada's vaccination drive slows down
as fewer people roll up their sleeves
could that lead to another surge
we don't know if you're one of the
people who get really sick or just a
little bit sick
that's why it's still important to get
vaccinated
the path to protecting interpreters who
help canadian troops in afghanistan
the risk of retribution from the taliban
is grave
what ottawa is promising explosive
and unpredictable strong winds fuel bc's
already intense wildfire fight
it was quite scary we just have no idea
of course how long it's going to be
plus how choking smoke is fast becoming
a summer health
hazard like chimney it can just build up
over time
the olympics opening ceremony kicks off
in a cloud
of controversy
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us as we head into a weekend
enjoying more freedoms thanks to a
hugely successful vaccination campaign
there are worries that it may not last
as the number of doses given out each
day
begins to plateau more than 80 percent
of eligible canadians have now at least
had one dose
but that number may not get much higher
about 18
of canadians say they aren't willing to
get vaccinated and that translates to
nearly
7 million people here unprotected
now several countries that have already
seen vaccination rates plateau
are now experiencing another surge in
cases
so the question is could canada be next
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
canadians are getting out and the
economy is recovering
the number of coveted cases
hospitalizations and deaths are all way
down
a major factor canada has one of the
most successful vaccination programs in
the world
but the numbers are plateauing in the uk
and the us
among the first to vaccinate widely
doses have stalled
canada had a higher vaccine distribution
but is also now slowing down
why it's important american and british
covit numbers are rising again
and while canada still has a very low
number of cases about 400 per day
will it last this is part of the trend
that
is concerning especially as we look
towards the fall
with the hope of reopening schools
especially
and making sure that people are
protected
the delta variant is so highly
contagious the unvaccinated are at much
higher risk of getting sick
alberta's medical officer of health
tweeted this week 91 percent of covet
deaths
and 95 percent of hospital and icu
admissions
were in those who did not have two doses
we will have to get that double
vaccination number up
otherwise we will still see people
getting sick but the vaccine uptake is
uneven across the country
big urban centers with high covet case
numbers are getting a big turnout
in alberta there are areas in both
calgary and edmonton where at least 60
percent of residents or more are fully
vaccinated
but in several rural locations in the
province just 30 percent or fewer have
been fully vaccinated
there's also a disparity among age
groups in ontario for example
little hesitancy among seniors over 75
percent have had two doses
but among young people age 12 to 29
fewer than 50 percent are fully
vaccinated
there are incentives such as this recent
pop-up clinic in toronto to make it easy
for young people to get their shots
other jurisdictions are looking at
incentives from prizes to lottery
tickets to reach those who are delayed
or hesitant we want people to be
incentivized to get the
vaccine it's clear and unequivocal that
we'll all benefit the higher the rates
of vaccination are in the country
canada has a high vaccination rate but
there's no guarantee that it's high
enough
to avoid another upsurge in covid the
message from doctors
get both doses and the sooner the better
eric sorensen global news
toronto and there are signs modernist
covet 19 vaccine
could soon be used more widely the
european union's drug regulator is
recommending the shop be approved for
kids aged 12 to 17.
a study of more than 3 700 children in
that age group
showed children produced an antibody
response comparable to that in adults
currently pfizer is the only shot
approved for 12 to 17 year olds in this
country
moderna submitted its application for
approval to health canada
in june more than 10 thousand food
workers in britain are getting
exemptions from quarantine rules
self-isolation requirements have led to
staff shortages and
empty shelves across england in what's
being dubbed a
ping democ phones have been inundated by
alerts after a surge in covet 19 cases
anyone pinged by the app is supposed to
self-isolate for 10 days
last week more than 500 thousand alerts
were sent out
australia's most populous state has
declared a national emergency as
it struggles to contain a surge in cases
of the
delta variant new south wales is
reporting the largest number of daily
new infections
since the pandemic began new zealand has
now suspended its quarantine free travel
bubble with australia
for two months after weeks of intense
pressure from canadian veterans
the federal government confirms it has
teams on the ground in afghanistan
working to bring interpreters and
support staff to canada
with the u.s pulling its troops out of
the country there has been
a growing urgency to get afghans who
worked with canadian forces
to safety mike armstrong reports
canada is here to support those who
supported us
it is according to the federal
immigration minister more than simply a
debt of gratitude
with the security situation in
afghanistan deteriorating by the day
canada he says has to do something
we have a moral obligation to do right
by them
now those are the words canadian
veterans have been using for weeks
pushing ottawa to rescue afghans who
worked with canada
while otto is acting most of the details
are being withheld for safety reasons
but the plan
is for arrivals to start in the coming
days and for a fairly wide eligibility
not just interpreters but other locally
hired staff as well
and their families without getting into
precise numbers we do anticipate that
the numbers will be in the several
thousands
global spoke to one of the interpreters
in afghanistan we're protecting his
identity he's in hiding
waiting to be moved out but he says he
watched the minister's press conference
live online very
super happy that i'm going to my country
to canada i'm super super happy in my
family
my little daughter and my younger
brother i have to be honest i'm
very emotional right now dave morrow is
one of the canadian veterans who's been
working on the campaign to pressure the
government
he says confirmation work is underway
has given him for the first time
real optimism but the clock is ticking
this is the the golden hour where we
have to ensure that their safety is is
protected
and that they stay safe and that we can
actually get them here before it's too
late
now one family watching closely is that
of captain
nicola goddard she was killed in a
battle with the taliban
15 years ago this past may her family
hopes her interpreter is now able to
come to canada
and questions whether anything would be
happening if veterans
hadn't put pressure on the government i
don't think so
i think the veterans who have stepped
forward and have been pushing this
for the last few months and also for the
last couple of years are really the
linchpin
some veterans are now turning to a next
phase they're collecting donations and
looking for volunteers to help afghans
with their resettlement here in canada
the job of giving back they say
is still far from over mike armstrong
global news
montreal now to bc where officials are
keeping a close eye on the fire
situation
and the role the hot dry weather may
play in making matters worse
conditions are extremely dry in the
southern half of the province
here is a look at images captured last
night at the inca meep creek wildfire
it's burning near
soyuz in bc's wine country the fire has
now
tripled in size as of tonight there are
270 wildfires actively burning across bc
85 of them are out of control more than
5
000 properties are under evacuation
order
more than 100 firefighters from quebec
are arriving in the province today to
help battle the fires
and another hundred from mexico are
expected this weekend
global's lauren pullen is in soyuz in
southern b.c for us tonight
tracking the incoming fire lauren what
is the latest on the situation there
pharah unfortunately the situation has
gone from
bad to worse with the smoke clearing
from the sky we did get a better picture
of just how massive this wildfire is
and it has exploded in size from 2 000
hectares
to 6800 hectares and even more people
had to pack up and leave their homes
last night after the wind unexpectedly
shifted
as of 2 pm this afternoon more than 700
property owners have been forced to flee
from the inca
creek wildfire alone but the community
of pharah really has
stepped up the penticton indian band is
opening up its doors to house any
evacuees who do need a place
to stay and more resources are also on
route to
fight the flames as this fire continues
to burn out of control
there is discussions around an
evacuation alert on highway
three there's no plans currently to have
a highway closure our operations section
chief has identified triggers that
would initiate a closure of the highway
there has been some damage to power
lines
and we're working with fortis to get any
power that has been lost restored
lauren a lot of people throughout bc's
fire zones are understandably on edge
tonight so is there any relief coming in
the weather forecast
unfortunately in the next few days it's
only expected to get hotter which is not
the news that those people who have been
forced to flee their homes
or those who have been told to be ready
to leave at a moment's notice
want to hear everyone of course is
anxiously waiting to see what does
happen next and livelihoods are on the
line too i spoke with the owners
of the three valley gap chateau a
popular tourist
spot just outside revelstoke with all
sorts of priceless artifacts
they are on evacuation order were forced
to cancel all reservations as a wildfire
is burning
on the hillside behind them as well but
they are confident that crews
are doing all that they can to keep
those flames at bay and they have hope
their family legacy will escape the
flames
we've been here for well we opened in
1960 with seven motel rooms and seven
seats in the coffee shop and my mom and
dad just kept on
building and building and for it to be
gone just doesn't still doesn't resonate
i
i can't see it happening and
unfortunately for
the situation here in soyuz those
temperatures are expected to hover
in the mid 30s for the next week with
no rain in sight pharah lauren pollen
and
soyuz tonight thank you lauren and
wildfire smoke it's wreaking havoc on
the air quality in several parts of the
country
advisories are in place in many cities
like calgary where a special air quality
statement was issued today
with a city hitting an eight or high on
the air quality health index
here's a look at the smoke hovering over
lake louise
and with the country's fire season off
to an early start the summer of smoke
while it'll likely be long heather ux
west reports on the
health consequences it's like one lock
up after another
the air surrounding ron jabegi's home
outside calgary
is heavy with smoke it's been this way
off and on for nearly a week
it's an irritant for most people but for
his two children
it's a much larger concern with cystic
fibrosis one of the issues is basically
airway clearance
so they're kind of thick and sticky in
there versus lubricated like you and i
would be and so the particles of smoke
and stuff
will build up alyssa and dylan are
staying
inside to be safe jabegi says they're
coping okay
but he worries about the potential
impact of a summer
filled with smoke it's something dr
courtney howard has
some experience with the emergency room
physician lives in the northwest
territories where in 2014 wildfires
blanketed the city of yellowknife
with smoke for more than two months i
ended up
flying down to see my dad in north
vancouver
and we opened up the suitcase and the
suitcase just smelled like
campfire dr howard co-authored a study
published
earlier this year in the british medical
journal the research found that the
smoke exposure in yellowknife that
summer led to an
increase in clinic visits for asthma
pneumonia and cough
er visits for asthma doubled while
pneumonia visits increased by 57 percent
people also um experience what we would
now probably describe as a feeling of
ecological grief or
eco anxiety people would say things like
if it's this bad now what does this mean
for our kids
howard says as periods of prolonged
wildfire smoke exposure become
more common communities will have to
prepare with things like designated
clean air centers and support for mental
health
ron jabegi says his family is taking the
summer a day at a time hoping
that clearer days are ahead heather urex
west global news
calgary under fire over taxpayer-funded
contracts
coming up so why did the conservative
leader hammer trudeau's liberals for
doing
the same thing
the federal conservatives are dealing
with heavy criticism after global news
reported the office of leader aaron
o'toole
awarded taxpayer-funded contracts to
friends and party insiders
and as our chief political correspondent
david aiken reports
he's also allowed a top aide to run a
side business
aimed at helping elect more social
conservatives david well pharah earlier
this year we learned that a federal
government contract a taxpayer-funded
contract
went to a company run by a close friend
of prime minister justin trudeau a
fellow named
tom pitfield and when the conservatives
found out about the pitfield contract
they went on the attack mr pitfield is
not just the prime minister buddy he's
also married
to the former liberal party president it
certainly
pays to be a liberal insider in ottawa
these days
but as global news has learned it also
looks like it pays to be
a conservative insider in his first six
months in office
o'toole awarded nearly 240 000
worth of taxpayer-funded contracts to
his supporters
and conservative insiders you can't be
giving out the
taxpayer money to your own insiders and
cronies so i think aaron is
has got himself locked into the same
kind of
you know old rum bottle politics on the
rito that people really don't like
that's not all o'toole has also allowed
a top aide
his deputy chief of staff steve outhouse
to run an outside business
that works to help some social
conservative candidates get on the
ballot in the next election
that business's revenue comes from party
donations
i were a conservative i'd be asking
questions of my leader
as to why he is taking sides in
nomination conventions
on the side of social conservatives and
the extreme right
the business arrangement is unusual
o'toole's office says
the house of commons was consulted and
none of it violates house rules
the bottom line to all this those
conservative attacks on liberal ethics
well they've now been blunted and that
work that o'toole's top aide is doing
well that has now renewed tensions
within the conservative party
between the social conservative wing and
other conservatives and
all of this on the eve of a likely late
summer election
farah david aiken in ottawa thank you
david
coyote ugly what's behind a series of
attacks in two provinces
a recent string of coyote attacks is
putting people in vancouver on edge
31 have been recorded in the city's
iconic stanley park this year
four coyotes were just euthanized as a
result and now officials are looking to
find
and put down another coyote that
attacked a jogger
late thursday but as karen lieberman
reports vancouver isn't the only city
facing coyote fears she's a really brave
dog
i just screamed for help but no one was
outside
as ten-year-old lily kwon recalls the
coyote attack that left her little
yorkshire terrier badly
injured this week something amiss in the
background
mid-interview a man appearing frightened
leaps from his scooter onto a parked car
oh i think he almost hit the car oh the
coyote's there
the coyote had returned and remained
unfazed by the global news crew before
it sauntered off
this is what i've been trying to tell
the city that we have aggressive
coyotes in the neighborhood as you can
see it actually chased
a grown man the quan's dog macy suffered
extensive injuries to her body
her attack was caught on security video
the family
certain the yorkie was trying to protect
lily from the coyote
neighbors say there are coyote sightings
in this area daily which concerns them
because at the center of the community
is this park which can be filled with
children playing
in fact a father tells us just this week
his daughter was swinging
when a coyote showed up and suddenly
somebody shout from there there's a
coyote there
so i saw it was going around behind and
then i
grabbed my wife and my daughter
especially because she was playing alone
at that time because we just live here
the city of toronto warns people should
not be feeding
wild animals the fact that they are
present
or even attack or or kill a pet
doesn't mean that the coyote will be
removed or
or euthanized it's as i say it's a
reality that coyotes do
exist in the city and even though i got
a big german shepherd
it's still scary because they're wild
you know it's at the end you got kids
yeah i just looked out the window and
there were some coyotes
roaming around as for macy
she's now out of hospital reunited with
her family and recovering at home
karen lieberman global news toronto
the olympic games have finally begun
officially next the mixed emotions for
canadians
in tokyo
the tokyo summer olympics officially
kicked off with the opening ceremony
in a near empty stadium of course
because of the pandemic
despite heavy restrictions kovit 19
cases are rising
in japan and among those involved in the
games including
athletes crystal command singh explains
a delayed but flashy opening to the
tokyo 2020 olympics
while athlete participation was limited
and seats
nearly empty pride filled the national
stadium
outside a very different mood
the prime minister of japan again
defended the decision to invite the
world
during the pandemic i believe that uh
beating
kovid 19 and overcoming the difficulties
of
kovit 19 to go ahead
with the games and to convene the games
i think
that has a value in itself strict rules
are in place for athletes media and
officials attending the games but the
virus is still spreading
19 new cases on friday alone
including three athletes the canadian
olympic committee says team canada
remains virus free i would like to
reassure all of those of you back in
canada
who have friends family loved ones here
in japan competing or supporting the
athletes
that the plans we have in place are
incredibly robust he's worked hard he's
focused
and he deserves it canadian sprinter
aaron brown's parents are in toronto
but say being on the track in tokyo
means everything to their son
we just said you know what we're behind
you no matter what happens over there
we're obviously here excited cheering
you on
it's been a tough and turbulent road to
tokyo the athletes
however are grateful for me personally
this is my one shot
you know i'm 34 years old if if softball
happens to be in the 2028 olympics i
will not be strapping on my cleats with
a cauldron now lit
let the games begin crystal gomencing
global news
london we are all cheering on team
canada from here that's it for global
national for this friday
i'm farah nasser thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is beautiful
georgian bay in ontario
we love seeing your canada so please
keep sending us your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com jeff
semple is going to be with you at the
anchor desk this weekend until monday
take care of yourselves and each other